o yavaş hepiniz hoş geldiniz Merhabalar
iyi bana Genellikle hep soruyu sorarlar
tarih ne işimize yarar Ben de onlara bir
cevap vermek zorundayım bunun içinde ona
gitmek zorundayım ama ondan önce kendimi
gitmek zorundayım bunun için verdiğim
bazı örnekler var yani tarih şu işimize
yarar bu işimize yarar çeşitli örnekler
var çok çeşitli Ben burada güzel bir
hikaye var o hikaye ile başlamak
istiyorum protokol kitaplarında bir
özellikle gördüğü için bazı anlatımlar
vardır ifadeler vardır Bunlardan bir
tanesi bir Amerikalı subay Türkiye'ye
geliyor ve Türkiye'ye geldiği zaman iyi
onu karşılayan bir iyi kendi
rütbesindeki bir yüz başı onunla
havaalanında
bu olay ve otele geçiyorlar ama bizimki
İngilizce bilmiyor sonra Amerikalı subay
ile sohbet ederken işte Otele mi gidelim
Yatalım mı yemek yiyelim önce diyor
yemek yiyelim Böyle vücut diliyle
anlaşıyorlar Ondan sonra birlikte otele
gidiyorlar yemek yiyorlar Yemeği
yedikten sonra yemeden önce bizim Türk
subay Afiyet olsun diyor Amerikalı su
bardağı yok herhalde ismini söyledi o da
kendi ismini söylemek için hafifçe şöyle
ediyorum ister Anderson diyor sen
değilsin söylüyor sonra kalkıyorlar
akşam yukarı çıkıyor ve bir arkadaşın
arıyor Türkçe bilen bir arkadaşının otel
odasında diyor ki böyle böyle gittik
beni karşıladılar ve işte sohbet ettik
adını öğrendik işte adı ne diyor adı
Afiyet olsun diyor O da diyor ki ya o
Afiyet olsun Adı değildir o
bu TM nedir Yani iyi yemekleri
yiyecekler anlamında bir şeydir
Dolayısıyla ismi değildir diyor öyle
deyince Ha öyle mi Ben de o zaman sabah
ona bir sürprizim yapayım diye ve sabah
kahvaltıda buluşuyorlar buluştuktan
sonra yemeğe başlamak için Amerikalı
subay Afiyet olsun diyor bizim su
bardağı Mısır Anderson diyor Tabii
bunlar eski kitaplarda yer alan ifadeler
güzel ifadeler yer Bunlar insana belli
protokol kurallarına öğretirler tarih
bilmemiz gerektiği zaman bu tarz şeyleri
de öğrenirsiniz öğrenmemiz gereken çok
şey olur Bugünü de etkiler Yani biz
bunun farkında olabiliriz veya olamayız
ama muhakkak ki günümüzde etkileyecektir
Bununla ilgili pek çok örnek verilebilir
şimdi bunlardan bir tanesi başlık
Öncelikle neden tarihi yap gelecek boş
çünkü tarihi doğru yaptığınız
ve gelecekte bunun yapbozunu doğru bir
şekilde yapabilirsiniz Aksi takdirde
hatalar yapabilirsiniz ders çıkarsanız
bazı şeyleri önceden anlayabilirsiniz
mesela eski devirlerde Osmanlı
Devleti'nin ekonomisinin zayıfladığı
devirlerde savaşlardan sonra vergiler
gittikçe yükseliyor Ama bu yetmemeye
başlar diyorlar ki artık vergi koymamız
lazım ek vergi koyuyorlar koydukları ek
vergide diyorlar ki geçici Savaş vergisi
geçici Savaş vergisi toplanıyor bu Tabii
bir nefes aldık duruyor maliyeye sonra
savaş bitiyor ama tabi devlet bu tarz
hazırdan gelen paralardan hiç vazgeçmek
istemez verginin adı değişiyor geçici
Barış vergisi olarak devam ediyor Yani
buradan mesela tarif biliyorsanız şunu
da aynı zamanda biliyorsunuz en kalıcı
şey geçici vergidir bu tarihin bize
öğrettiği şeylerden bir tanesi ama ben
tüm bunların dışında özellikle
anlattığım bir hikaye vardır şöyle
rivayet olmuş Alparslan Romen diyojen'i
Malazgirt Savaşı'nda yeni pes edince
karşısında oturuyor Romen Diyojen dedim
ki acaba ne soracak işte şöyle mi
yapacak böyle yapacak böyle heyecanlı
tarih okur musunuz diyor buna diyor Şu
anda şaşırıyor Yani normalde sorulması
gereken soru tarihi okur musun değil
işte İhtiyat askeri var mı hazinelerde
Bunları sorması lazım ama tarihi okur
musunuz O da dedi ki yok Biz daha çok
işte matematik var bizde Tıp var
astronomi falan var kostik filmler var
güzel Alparslan da belli zaten tarihi
okumadığınız diyor bu düzeni Roman diyor
Can şaşırıyor nereden belli Nereden
anladınız diyor O da diyor ki tarihi
okusaydın bu savaşta bana yenilmezdin
çünkü aynı taktikle daha önce de
yenilmiştir iz
o tarih Niye bilmek zorunda olduğumuz
bazen zorunda değiliz ama bilmek bize
çok şeyler kazandırabilir Tabii işin
içerisine girdikçe bir akademik bir anda
anlamda yaklaştığınız zaman pek çok
detaylar olduğunu görüyorsunuz iş
çatallaşıyor pek çok Mesela bugün
savunma sanayinde kullanılan kompozit
malzemeler var bunların Aslında eskiye
dayandığını görüyorsunuz bunlardan bir
tanesi mesela yaydır yay için önce bu
görmüş olduğunuz Akçaağaç var burada
ağacı alıyorsunuz güzel bir şekilde
ve o harfine benzer şekilde
katılıyorsunuz ve duvara atıyorsunuz ya
yapmak için ve bu duvarda bir sene çivi
asılı bekliyor Yani sabah ustaya uğradım
Ustam akşama bana bir ya yap değil Bunu
bir Sen önceden söylemeniz lazım ya
yapmanız için Bu da yeterli değil bir
manda boynuzu kullanıyorlar bunu dikine
kesiyorlar iki tane çok esnek malzeme
elde ediyor Böylelikle yayınağacı
kırılmayacak Ama son derece esnek bir
yapısı sebebiyle de gelelim kuvveti çok
alacak tabi bunlar da yetmiyor başka bir
şey daha temin etmeniz lazım büyükbaş
hayvanların Aşil tendonu yani ayak
bileklerini arkasında bulunan şurada
bulunan Aşil tendonu buradaki sinirleri
kurutuyorlar çıkartıyorlar boynuz ile
ağacın arasına koyuyorlar birbirlerine
sürterken boynuz ağacı Elit Mason
randevu Mason diye peki bunun için bakım
Botanik ile ilgili
bu zorlu ile ilgili şeyler var peki bu
yeterli mi Hayır değil Çünkü siz Mersin
balığı yoksa Elinizde iyi yayı hala
yapamazsınız Çünkü orta çam en güçlü
tutkalını kullanmak zorundasınız bunun
içinde Mersin balığının damağında bir
hava kesesi var bu Orta Çağ'ın en güçlü
tutkalı dır bunu kullanmak zorundasınız
yani bayağı yapmadım işin ne kadar çok
Detay olduğunu anlatmaya çalışıyorum
Dolayısıyla bütün bunları bir sene
içerisinde bir araya getirdiğiniz zaman
ortaya böyle bir şey çıkıyor yani
zannettiğimiz den çok daha kapsamlı bir
iş Diğer taraftan da mesela müzelerde
gördüğünüz Kılıçlar vardır ince bir
Çelik görürsünüz Aslında görmüş
olduğunuz Çelik 16 kattır Çelik döverim
uzatılır ikiye katlanır tekrar dövülür
uzatılır tam 16 Kat çelik tel Ama siz
tek kat gibi görürsünüz bütün askerimizi
gezdirirken bir arkadaşıma bunu söyledim
hani biliyorsunuz falan
de böyle böyle deyince arkadaşımız da
yok bilmiyoruz dedi hani biz sen
Yeniçeri ağası iken Biz askerlik
yapmamıştır nereden bilelim şeklinde bir
şey söylemiştim şimdi tarihte bazı zeki
insanlar var Bunlar tarihi müthiş bir
şekilde değiştirebiliyor lar olayların
gidişatını değiştirebiliyor larçin
Bunlar mesela bunlardan bir tanesi
askeri tarih bakımından baktığımız zaman
Büyük İskender bir savaşı var Kavga
Medya Savaşı diye her kırıldı dariusla
savaşıyorlar bu savaşta şöyle bir taktik
düzen oluyor buna tabi ediyoruz ve şöyle
bir dizilim var yani İskenderun ordusu
İki tarafa ayrılıyor tersin Pers
ordusunun 4 Ana kısma ayrılıyor
gerisinde dariusu var bu görmüş
olduğunuz dizilim bir süre sonra farklı
aşacak başka ulaşacak ne yapılacak
burada aynı zamanda arıyorsun yani ters
kıralım
bu ordusunda savaş arabaları var bu
savaş arabaları ile alakalı da tarih
belirler Bazen sizin farkında olmazsınız
derken benzer şeylerden bahsediyoruz
Mesela bu savaş arabasının başka bir
yerden getirelim konuyu mesela o uzay
roketleri nden bahsedelim uzay
roketlerinin yakıt depoları genişti
yaklaşık bir buçuk metredir bilinen bir
hikayedir ama hiç rastlayan var mı
bilmiyorum duyan var mı bir buçuk metre
genişliğindedir bunun sebebi nedir çünkü
bunlar kiren rayı ile gitmek zorundadır
aradılar ve tren rayı da gitmek
zorundadır dünyanın her yerindeki tren
raylarının aralığında 143 buçuk
santimdir Rusya hariç onlar Avrupalı
bizi işgal etmesine 155 santim
genişliğinde yapmışlardır ve Avrupalılar
çile Rusya giremem işlerdir Peki neden
143 buçuk santimdir bunun Bir sebebi mi
var Evet bunun bir sebebi var Çünkü
buradaki demiryollarını ama
ve demiryollarını İngiliz göçmenler
yaptığı ilk defa İngiltere'den gelen
göçmenler yaptı neden bu genişlikte
yaptılar Çünkü İngiltere'deki tramvay
Yolları bu genişlikte yapılıyordu
Amerika'dan İngiltere geçtik Peki onlar
neden bu Aralıkta yapıyorlardır Bridge
Çünkü eskiden at arabalarının
genişlikleri tekerlerin genişlikleri bu
143 buçuk santim yaklaşır genişlik
değildi Peki o niye o kadar genişlik
Lady Çünkü İngiltere'ye en uzun yolu
yapan askeri Yolları yapan Romalılar the
ve romalıların arabaların at arabaların
tekerlekleri bu Aralık taydı bu
arabaların tekerlekleri neden böyleydi
Çünkü iki tane attı yan yana
getirirseniz at arabasının tekerleği
yaklaşık o dönem 143 buçuk santim
olmuştur ve bugünkü uzay roketleri yakıt
farkını genişliğini belirler her Mesela
tarih sizi fa
eve girmeden yönlendirir yönetir Siz
bunun farkında bazen varsınız bazen
varamazsınız hikaye tekrar buraya
döndürelim darius'un yani Pers kralının
elinde savaş arabaları var bu savaş
arabalarının nasıl durduracağını
planlıyor uzun mızraklı adamlarıyla önce
bu her Savaş arabasını karşısına kimler
oluşturuyor sonra bu tüplerin ağızlarını
bu şekilde açıyor ve at arabasının
sürenler bu azacık kimden içerisinde
gelecek mızraklarla öldürüyorlar ve
arabaları İskender ele geçiriyor 1-0
önde sonra hala İskenderun ordusu 45 bin
kişi hala Darius ikiyüzbin ki yani bir
zeka bunu hala tam tersine çevirmiş
değil Peki bunu nasıl yapacak kendisi
sağ tarafa geçiyor v-papel paslar adı
verilen son derece Bıçkın bir şekilde
savaşan piyadeleri var Bunları gizlice
Kendi bulunduğu sağ taraftaki Süvari
bu atla askerlerin arkasına saklıyor ve
sağ tarafa doğru şöyle bir manevra
yapıyor bu manevranın sonucunda da
yüzüyor ki beni dışarıdan kuşatacak
Dolayısıyla ben de sol tarafı
kaydırıyorum bu şekilde yaptığı zaman
İskender zaten Savaşı kazanmış oluyor
Neden diyeceksiniz Çünkü Harekat planı
şu şekilde Ben bütün orduyu gelmeme
gerek yok Sadece dariusu Hedef Alıp onu
yok edersem Savaşı kazanırım yapmaya
çalıştığı şey buydu arada bir boşluk
oluşup bu boşluğu kendisi açtırıp direkt
hedefe gitmek ve direk hedefe gitti ve
savaşı kazandı Peki aklınıza şöyle bir
soru gelebilir ya hocam o zaman Bunlar
da geri kapanır kapanıyorlar Çünkü o
gizlenen piyade askerleri darius'un
kapanacak sol kanadına anzhı olunca
İskender da süvarileri ile birlikte
doğrudan hedefe gidiyor yani tarihte
görülen en müthiş muharebelerden bir
tanesidir bir adamın basit bir mana
en iyi taktik harekatla Savaşı kazanması
benzer bir şey şurada var çamurun dergi
savaşında var Şu vurun ordusumu
karşısında Hint ordusu var Ve şimdi
ordusunda filler var yani karşı tarafın
askeri tabi de sıklet Merkezi ağırlık
merkezi vurucu gücü filler timur'a
diyorlar ki karşı tarafı filler var
şimdi burada tabii Tamam diyor Gereğini
yapacağız ve Benim anlamadığım bir
şekilde ben bunu anlatırken hep şöyle
anlatırım itiraf olarak anlatırım dedim
ki işte bu filler Durdurulamaz ama ön
Safa iki sıra de düzüyor sonra bu
develeri zincirlerle birbirine bağlıyor
arkasına mızraklı piyadeleri
yerleştirmek için Normalde önde olması
lazım onların olan arkasında okçuluğu
yerleştiriyor ben bunu ilk gördüğüm
zaman bunu bir çocuk çizmiş dedim İşin
doğrusu Ama bunu bir çocuk çizmem işte
bir savaş dâhisi çizmişti ve Savaşı
Tersine çevirmiştir çok güçlü olan
düşmanı yenmişti bunu nasıl yaptı
develerin sırtına saman balyaları
yükledi
o zaman yılını ateşleyin cebirden o
Develer zavallı hayvan cihazlar yanan
ateşin etkisiyle zincirlerle bağlı
olduklarından ne sahnesi olur eve
dönemiyorlar Direk karşıya doğru
gidiyorlar ve karşıya doğru gittikleri
zaman benim bilmediğim ne biliyordu
Timur fillerin en korktuğu şeyin Ateş
olduğunu biliyordu Ve o filler geri
dönerek karşı tarafın kendi askerlerini
ayaklarıyla paspas gibi Tabiri caizse
çiğnediler o fillerin ayaklarının
altından kurtulanları arkadan Develer
Çiğnedi Onlar hala ölmediyse develerin
sırtında dökülen samanlar veya yanıcı
malzemeler yaktı onun arkasında benim
burada ne işi var dediğim mızraklı
piyadeler Tabiri caizse yağdan elma
gibi ilerlediler en önden
kaçanları Okçular Işıtmak atışla en ön
tarafa zarar verir dünya Hatay'ın en
kolay muharebesini kazandıran Bu bir
adamın zekası bu
Bu plandaydı bir örnekte Fatih Sultan
Mehmet'ten vereceğim bu da maalesef
bilinmiyor hem teknoloji tarihine dair
bir şeydir bu hem de aslında
öğrendiğimiz zaman ya evet bu niye
düşünmemiş diyoruz şimdi İstanbul'un
surları Fatih'ten önce de dövüldü
toplamda ilk defa Fatih değil ama
yıkılmadı neden yıkılmadı şöyle surlar
vardır toplarla vuruyor vuruyor ama
duvar bir türlü delinmiyor Fatih Sultan
Mehmet bunun yolunu bulduk ne yapacağım
dedi Dedi ki şu toplarla yani şahit
toplarıyla ve havan toplarıyla özür
dilerim küçük toplarla bunları yok
edeceğim Bunu nasıl yaptı küçük topları
küçük olduğu için delme ucu daha fazla
ne yapıyor gücün uygulandığı alan
daraldıkça basınç artıyor küçük toplarla
sulu deldi ve delmiş olduğu surlar şu
şekildeydi AİO ortada görmüş olduğunuz
kırmızı küçük
Bu bir yuvarlak teşkil etti ve etrafı
kesmiş oldular ortaya atmış olduğu büyük
top zaten etrafı kesilmiş olan duvarı 52
günde yıkmış Oldu oldu ve bu bütün her
tarihini değiştiren bir şey oldu artık
Bendeki böyle kaleler olmaz yeni bir
teknoloji yeni bir anlayış lazım sürekli
bunu yaptılar ve şöyle bir Yıldıztabya
dediğimiz ya tras İtalyan denilen bir
form ortaya çıktı top çarptı zaman
seksin direkt duvarı patlatmaz ve bütün
Avrupa kalemi Mahallesi'ni değiştirdi bu
maalesef Biz de çok böyle anlatılmıyor
çok da bilinmiyor eski tip sorular şöyle
de yüksek diler ama aşağıdan vurduğunuz
zaman üst tarafları kolayca devrile
biliyordu ama yeni Türk Sur şu şekilde
oldu için sıkıştırılmış toprak ve yatık
Aynı zamanda da yıldız şeklinde topu
atıyorsunuz çarpan top seçiyor hem yana
doğru söylüyor hem yukarı doğru çekiyor
ve yukarıda da
Ben onlarla karşı tarafı durdura
biliyorsunuz Peki biz bunları bilerek ne
işe ne işimize bugün yarayabilir Bunları
bilmek burada bir zırh görüyorsunuz Bu
sırttan önceki zırhla zincir şeklinde
zincirleri Halkalı demire birbirine
bağlıyorsunuz ve gömlek şeklinde
üzerinize gidiyordunuz fakat giymiş
olduğunuz bu zırhlar bir süre sonra
darbelere karşı dayanıksız hale geldi ve
İnsanoğlu dedi ki böyle yapmayalım bir
çözüm bulalım
da aynı kale mimarisindeki gibi bir
mühimmat çarptığı zaman seksin yan
tarafa doğru git Dolayısıyla artık
zırhları bu şekilde yaptılar ok ve
mızrak gelip çarptığı zaman yan tarafa
doğru sekti Peki bunlar ilk tanklar
nasıllar Bunlar dümdüz gez hiç eğim yok
nedenim Yok eski çağdaki saçlardan ders
alınmamış yani mühimmatın sökeceği
hesaplanmamış pa-100 Yüzyıllar boyunca
pek çok muharebenin dersi çıkarılmadığı
için bunu deliyordu ve 100.000 on
binlerce insan hiç değilse Bunun
içerisinde feci bir şekilde yanarak Can
veriyordu Günümüzde ise İnsanoğlu artık
tarihten ders almayı öğrendi ve artık
bunları yapıyor yiyerek sunumu
tamamlıyorum Hepinize çok teşekkür
ederim sağ ol